the most dangerous thing in the bush is
humanity your life is always risk you
can die at any time
[Music]
my name is Jacob I work in open data as
our knowledge which I know Gattaca a
minute Oh Peter
Yannick you owe me money another white
rain
my name is James McKee attack off the
Northern Lights
[Music]
Ringo
my name is Joseph I am a caregiver of
the an overnight fire
and then David in final kasi applied no
pattern
I'm Daniel Maliki I'm the head of an -
pushing you natal predator my main work
is to provide security to world Rey and
also the neighboring community my name
is John tequila's unfortunate W my name
is Frederick I work here
and PSC or public animal conflict and
actually is a very critical job because
there is a great animal conflicts with
people outside surrounding the park
[Music]
the Wellington a Romans God created man
the main job that man was given he was
told protect the nation and I believe
and being what I am meant to be in a
good modern embedded in religion confer
alia - alia anima Fukuyama Indian
fighter is a key ally of my father
Penta I am a son of San Geronimo Yama
come on toto
I am here taking care of animals is
really good especially working with spam
and the Northern Lights so that is the
last not only left in the world
each happen to die I feel that as hard
he's everything to me Ringo is more or
less like a human child requires a lot
of attention so fireman during most to
stay single
I'm keeping him away from the rain I
love him very much and I think even he
loved me very much at the moment I am
like his talent when I found him that
morning and he was so weak and so skinny
and now that is growing to be a big boy
it brings me so much joy
[Music]
Valene on a well put a view that is of
people but their idols they just killed
them because of only haunts and if you
look at for any phones
it is just something is very common it
is like our fingernails glue to embrace
are the ways of hanging money with this
level of joblessness amongst young
people leaving the easiest way would be
to risk your lives and kill animals just
to give the money leave these rhinos
would go hexton we all would they get
this money so many people they are
killing the animal and they are
destroying Benicia it's why we are
working so hard if you ever had a chance
to see when our eye has been poached
it's a horrible scene so it's really a
sad thing especially forest rangers was
there something that you risk your life
for every day you wake up to monitor
rhinos
you face elephants lions every day but
only one night a poacher comes and kills
the animal so mercilessly we don't care
where it was a female
a that was pregnant with another calf
they just kill it
it's really it's really painful and a
very horrible scene
it is more important for me to commit
myself to test the communities outside
there that never came this animal
because in this animal they benefit to
tourism and also these conservation
creating without blame a very good role
not only in open data but also in the
country number the eros of these
countries we are not doing it for all
bigotry we are not doing it for yourself
we are doing it for the nation
it is a high time that we need to be the
guardians of whatever I will given to a
hoss nature as beautiful it is we need
to make sure it's well protected these
animals are helpless humans of power we
need to be their voice
[Music]
[Music]